[Music]
Flint effect is this kind of startling
finding that IQ scores scores on IQ
tests around the world are in the 20th
century have been rising at a pretty
steady rate of about 3 points per decade
and not only have they been rising at 3
points per decade but the scores are
rising on the most abstract tests and
the most abstract parts of tests so for
example the tests that has the height
the fastest rise in scores is called
Ravens progressive matrices this has
nothing to do with anything you've
learned in school
it's just patterns abstract patterns in
a sequence and one is missing and you
have to figure out how to fill in the
missing patterns it's pure abstraction
this test was created so that you
wouldn't have to bring anything to it
that you've learned in life if Martians
landed on earth this was supposed to be
the test that can determine how clever
they work and yet it's the place where
we've seen the fastest rise in scores in
this abstract thinking skills that
aren't really specifically taught
anywhere
when James Flynn the professor who first
noticed this trend for whom the Flynn
effect is named started wondering what
was going on he went back to some famous
studies by a Soviet psychologist named
Alexander Lauria and Luria found an
incredible natural experiment in the
1930s when the Soviet Union was
nationalizing essentially some of the
remote territories villages that had not
been developed for agriculture and they
wanted to develop industry in those
places
Lauria wondered if taking people who
were living in what he called a
pre-modern sort of environment where
they were subsistence farmers and
quickly moving them into modern work
where they had to work together and
coordinate schedules and coordinate
tasks for agriculture you even have some
schooling in some cases how would that
change the way that they think and so he
saw this natural experiment where he
came in the middle of this revolution
where some of these pre-modern villagers
again using his terminology were still
in their their original environment as
subsistence farmers and others were
getting connected to the modern world
and getting a little bit
school is somewhere being trained to be
teachers others were being appointed to
head collective farms and had to start
managing people and thinking ahead and
and and setting long term sort of
complicated goals and what he found was
that this actually had a profound effect
on the very way that they think when the
pre-modern villagers were given skins of
wool or silk of different colors and
hues and asked to organize them into
groups they basically said it can't be
done none of them are similar
whereas when some of the villagers who
had been touched by modernity were given
this same task they pretty easily
grouped them into colors even if they
didn't really have names for those
colors they started to recognize the
abstraction of a color for use in
grouping and the same thing was true
with shapes so for example a 26 year old
remote villager named Ali Ewa was asked
to group certain shapes together but to
her a square with a with a solid line
was obviously a map and the same square
with a dotted line was obviously a watch
she could only see them as these
concrete objects whereas the villagers
who had started to interact with the
modern world were used to abstract
classifications and even if they didn't
know the names of the shapes they
recognized that the concept was the same
and they could group them together and
so that's just sort of one example but
in all of these tests what
Lauria noticed was that the pre-modern
villagers were grounded in the concrete
in their own direct experience they
could only answer questions based on
concrete objects that they had directly
experienced where the greater the dose
of modernity that villagers had had the
more they had to engage in complex
interconnected work the more they were
able to group things with with abstract
concepts to use classification schemes
or what James Flynn came to call
scientific spectacles he'd say they see
the world through scientific spectacles
some of the ways that modern work
changed the very thinking of pre-modern
villagers are sort of miraculous on the
screen is a famous example called the
Ebbinghaus illusion and if you're
watching this then you're clearly
engaged in modern work and in the modern
world and I want you to tell me which
one of the central circles looks larger
and again since you're engaged in modern
the circle on the right probably looks
larger the big one surrounded by smaller
circles but pre-modern villagers
actually saw correctly that both central
circles are actually the same exact size
and scientists who studied this think
that this has to do with how we
differently perceive these circles in
relation to one another so for the
pre-modern villagers they see each
individual circle they're not as drawn
to the holistic context and so they can
accurately see the size of the central
circles whereas people who are more used
to abstraction and thinking of things in
classification and in relation to one
another are more drawn to the holistic
context so the contrast between the
circles affects your perception now we
in our modern work world have to use
abstraction constantly we have to apply
our knowledge to situations that we've
never actually seen before and we get by
on that it's called transfer we have to
take knowledge from one place and use
the concepts and apply them to something
we've never seen before and there's
evidence that the act of doing that has
continued to make us better and better
at this sort of abstract thinking that
shows up on the Ravens progressive
matrices so modernity has essentially
changed the way we think to make us
better and using broad abstract abstract
concepts and applying them to situations
that are unfamiliar to us and it's not
to say that one type of thinking is
better than the other that's certainly
not the case they're just adapted to
different conditions so whereas the
pre-modern villagers kind of wood to use
familiar terms often miss the forest for
the trees they don't see the holistic
concept of these groupings
whereas we in the industrialized world
will often miss the trees for the forest
we see these broader concepts but
sometimes not the individual concrete
details that they do
[Music]